Hi, it's Joel Blackstock with the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast, and today I'm going to read an article from our blog at GetTherapybirmingham.com called Nothing Gold Can Stay, a thought experiment about money, power, wealth, and the psychology of economy. So what do we value as people, as a society? It's important to note that in this article, this is a thought experiment for the purpose of reconsidering our implicit assumptions and societal conceptions of the necessities for civilization and the norms that make us human. In the article or the podcast about mysticism, I pointed out that I was a psychotherapist and not a theologian. And here I need to point out that I am not an economist either. This is a thought experiment and it is not advocating for any kind of specific new political or economic reality.
大家好，我是来自Taproot Therapy Collective播客的Joel Blackstock。今天我将朗读我们博客GetTherapybirmingham.com上的一篇文章，题目是《金子终将褪色》（Nothing Gold Can Stay），这是一个关于金钱、权力、财富和经济心理学的思想实验。那么，作为个人、作为社会，我们究竟看重什么？需要指出的是，这篇文章是一个思想实验，旨在重新审视我们对文明必需品以及构成人类规范的隐含假设和社会观念。在关于神秘主义的文章或播客中，我曾指出我是一名心理治疗师，而非神学家。在这里，我也需要说明我并非经济学家。这只是一个思想实验，并不主张任何特定的政治或经济现实。
Instead, it's a way to consider the things that we take for granted and meditate on new ideas that might allow us to conceive of a healthier or more stable society. So if we didn't have gold, if we didn't have the noble metals on the periodic table like iridium and silver and platinum that are not very reactive, What would money have looked like? You know, these metals are non-perishable, the precious metals, and there's not a lot of other goods that we can make that hold value in the way that they do. They're in a small convenient package and they have a high luster and malleability. They don't spoil with age. How would society store value without something like gold? Well, there are a couple examples of how money developed in places without gold, and my favorite is an island called Yap, where there was little to no money. It's a, you know, a pre-industrial society that hadn't been discovered by any empire yet. And so the native Yippies used these 20-foot-tall limestone disks
相反，这是一种审视我们视为理所当然的事物，并沉思那些可能让我们构想出更健康或更稳定社会的新观念的方法。那么，如果我们没有黄金，如果我们没有元素周期表中像铱、银、铂这样化学性质不活泼的贵金属，金钱会是什么样子呢？你知道，这些金属是不可腐烂的贵金属，而且我们能制造的、能像它们那样保值的商品并不多。它们体积小巧、携带方便，且具有高光泽度和延展性。它们不会随时间而腐烂。如果没有黄金之类的东西，社会将如何储存价值？嗯，有一些关于在没有黄金的地方金钱是如何发展的例子，我最喜欢的是一个叫雅浦岛的地方，那里几乎没有货币。这是一个前工业化社会，当时还没有被任何帝国发现。所以当地的雅浦人使用这些20英尺高的石灰岩圆盘
that weighed hundreds of pounds for money. So how did this kind of money work? How do you put a 200-pound, or in some cases, like 500-pound stone tablet in your pocket or in a vending machine or slide it across a bar to use it as money. Well, the Yippies never moved the stones that they used as money. Instead, they kept an oral and societal ledger of who owned what stone, which is really all that's important about money is somebody remembering who owns it.
作为货币，这些圆盘重达数百磅。那么这种货币是如何运作的呢？你如何把一块200磅，或者在某些情况下500磅重的石板放进你的口袋、投进自动售货机，或者在酒吧里滑过去当作钱使用？嗯，雅浦人从不移动他们用作货币的石头。相反，他们保留了一份口头的、社会的账本，记录谁拥有哪块石头，而这实际上就是金钱最重要的意义——有人记得谁拥有它。
And so money that can't fit into your wallet might seem like a crazy idea, but think about how your debit card works. There's this collective ledger somewhere out there that changes every time you slide your card, even though no physical money is moved. And we really can't even keep track of it in our heads, but we trust that someone is doing it right, and collectively, you know, we all kind of do it the same way. That's how the money on Yap worked.
所以，无法放进钱包的钱听起来可能很疯狂，但想想你的借记卡是如何运作的。每当你刷卡时，某个地方就会有一个集体账本发生变化，尽管没有任何实物货币被移动。我们甚至无法在脑海中追踪它，但我们相信有人在正确地处理它，而且集体地，你知道，我们都以同样的方式行事。这就是雅浦岛货币的运作方式。
So on this island of Yap, the acquisition and distribution of Rai stones, Rai is what they called the money, R-A-I, they were tied to social merit and prestige so somebody owned the money no one could take it from them it wasn't a communist society they got to choose who it gave the money to
所以在雅浦岛，Rai石（Rai是他们对货币的称呼，拼写为R-A-I）的获取和分配与社会功绩和声望挂钩。所以有人拥有这笔钱，没人能从他们那里夺走。这不是一个共产主义社会，他们可以选择把钱给谁。
but there's social pressures maybe in that same way there is in capitalism if you're a billionaire you have to start a non-profit or you have to be benevolent in some way to make an argument for your worth in society. And so this process of awarding the Rye Stones on the Yap Island, it was based on various factors that reflected an individual status, achievements, and contributions to the community. Now, I mean, somebody could just take one and say, I'm never going to give it to anybody. I'm going to take all these. That was an option available. But generally, there's this tendency in the money on YAP to give it to people who deserve it or who have given back
但存在社会压力，也许就像资本主义中那样，如果你是亿万富翁，你必须创办非营利组织，或者必须以某种方式行善，才能证明你在社会中的价值。因此，在雅浦岛授予Rai石的过程，是基于反映个人地位、成就和对社区贡献的各种因素。现在，我的意思是，有人可以拿走一块说：“我永远不会把它给任何人。我要把这些全拿走。”这是一个可行的选择。但通常情况下，雅浦岛的货币有一种倾向，即把它给那些值得拥有或回馈了社会的人。
to society in some meaningful way. So the primary means of acquiring a rye stone was through social recognition and acknowledgement of an individual's accomplishments. And these accomplishments could include successful leadership or an act of bravery or notable achievements in various fields like agricultural development, craftsmanship, diplomacy. And there seemed to be this respected method of noticing when somebody did this well, and then somebody stepping up to kind of pay them a rye stone. Granted, these stones never moved. They sat there. And the society said, this new person owns this new stone. There's even one story about how they were moving one of the stones in between the islands just to kind of transfer it. And it sank. And everybody was like,
以某种有意义的方式回馈社会。因此，获取Rai石的主要方式是通过社会认可和对他个人成就的承认。这些成就可能包括成功的领导力、勇敢的行为，或在农业发展、工艺、外交等各个领域的显著成就。似乎有一种受人尊敬的方法，即注意到某人做得很好，然后有人站出来给他们一块Rai石。当然，这些石头从不移动。它们就放在那里。社会说，这个新人拥有这块新石头。甚至有一个故事说，他们正在岛屿之间移动其中一块石头以便进行转让。结果它沉了。每个人都觉得，
well, okay, it sank into the ocean, but it's still there. So, I mean, we'll just keep it going. And so, you know, a group of people or a family or whatever at different points, they owned the stone that was under the ocean that no one would ever get back. But it was still money, still there, still part of the system. This is just one thought experiment about what money might look like without gold, but it's kind of an interesting one. And so this recognition of awarding rye stones to different people, it was carried out through public ceremonies and gatherings. And these events provided a platform for the community to acknowledge
好吧，它沉入大海了，但它还在那里。所以，我的意思是，我们会继续使用它。所以，你知道，一群人或一个家庭或什么的，在不同的时间点，他们拥有那块沉在海底、没人能拿回来的石头。但它仍然是钱，仍然在那里，仍然是系统的一部分。这只是关于没有黄金时金钱可能是什么样子的一个思想实验，但这确实是一个有趣的实验。因此，这种授予不同人Rai石的认可，是通过公开仪式和聚会进行的。这些活动为社区提供了一个平台来承认
and celebrate the achievements of an individual. The stones were typically presented by influential community leaders or elders who acted as arbiters of the social merit of the community, sometimes secular, sometimes more religious. And it's important to note, though, that the awarding of Rye Stones was not this purely individualistic pursuit, but it was rather a collective decision. So even though the individual owned it, the individual could reward it, there is social pressure that if you have not done a good job at something for a while and somebody else is doing a good job, you probably need to give them a Rye Stone to compensate them. There's that pressure that's always acting on this monetary system. So these rye stones, they were bestowed upon an individual, but they couldn't be hoarded or accumulated solely for personal wealth. It would be very hard, nigh impossible for somebody to own all of them in Yap culture. And so this Yapese
并庆祝个人的成就。这些石头通常由有影响力的社区领袖或长者颁发，他们充当社区社会功绩的仲裁者，有时是世俗的，有时更具宗教色彩。但需要注意的是，授予Rai石并非纯粹的个人主义追求，而是一个集体决定。所以即使个人拥有它，个人可以奖励它，但存在一种社会压力：如果你有一段时间没有做好某事，而别人做得很好，你可能需要给他们一块Rai石作为补偿。这种压力始终作用于这个货币系统。所以这些Rai石被授予个人，但不能被囤积或仅仅为了个人财富而积累。在雅浦文化中，一个人想要拥有所有这些石头是非常困难，甚至是不可能的。所以这个雅浦
monetary system, it served as this tangible representation that Rhinestones did and the social contract that kept them moving. It served as this tangible representation of honor and status, and it reinforced the social fabric and common good of the YAP society. So in answer to the original question, how could society store value without gold? I'm not going to bore you with like 800 examples of pre-industrial societies forming their own monetary system. Even across sometimes pretty vast empires like in Africa. The answer is if you don't have a precious metal, what you usually revolve your society around storing wealth in is something like reputation or honor social merit.
货币系统，它作为一种有形的代表，Rai石确实做到了，还有维持它们流动的社会契约。它作为荣誉和地位的有形代表，加强了雅浦社会的社会结构和共同利益。所以回答最初的问题，社会如何在没有黄金的情况下储存价值？我不会用800个前工业化社会形成自己货币系统的例子来让你感到厌烦。即使在非洲这样有时非常广阔的帝国中也是如此。答案是，如果你没有贵金属，你通常围绕储存财富来构建社会的，是声誉或荣誉、社会功绩之类的东西。
There's a system that props up that rewards benevolence and generosity and innovation in the way that sometimes, um, you know, precious metal back systems or debt back system don't do. And so the people who gave back to society the most in these pre-industrial societies, they would be awarded the most value in the form of reputation and not by how many precious metals or how much debt or bland or, you know, whatever the scarcity, uh, thing is, but reputation. So how did something like gold change our conception of society and culture? So gold has long fascinated humanity because it has this allure. Um, it's very rare. Um, it's needed for a lot of things
有一个系统支持并奖励仁慈、慷慨和创新，这在有时，嗯，你知道，贵金属支持的系统或债务支持的系统所做不到的。因此，在这些前工业化社会中，对社会回馈最多的人，会以声誉的形式获得最大的价值，而不是通过拥有多少贵金属、多少债务或土地，或者，你知道，无论稀缺的东西是什么，而是声誉。那么像黄金这样的东西是如何改变我们对社会和文化的构想的呢？黄金长期以来一直让人们着迷，因为它有一种魅力。嗯，它非常稀有。嗯，它在很多方面都是必需的。
it's non-perishable in that it doesn't go away you can throw a bunch of gold in a dungeon and then a hobbit can come reclaim it in a thousand years, nothing happens to it if you did that with wheat or clothing or something, they'd be rotted and out of date
它是不可腐烂的，因为它不会消失。你可以把一堆金子扔进地牢，然后一个霍比特人可以在一千年后回来取回它，它什么事都没有。如果你用小麦、衣服或其他东西这样做，它们早就腐烂过时了。
even buildings, they require maintenance if you leave a building for a thousand years, it's gone. So there's nothing that really holds value in the way that gold does because gold's properties don't change. So if there were a couple changes to the astrophysical geometry of our universe, um, we wouldn't have enough gold on this planet. So, you know, why is gold on earth and what is our relationship to it? So in a lot of psychology and myths, gold is representative of the self. You go on this trip to reclaim gold, but really
即使是建筑物，也需要维护。如果你把一栋建筑留一千年，它就没了。所以没有什么东西能像黄金那样真正保值，因为黄金的性质不会改变。所以如果我们的宇宙天体几何结构发生了一些变化，嗯，我们在这个星球上就不会有足够的黄金。所以，你知道，为什么地球上有黄金，我们与它的关系是什么？所以在很多心理学和神话中，黄金是自我的代表。你踏上这段旅程去取回黄金，但实际上
along the way you find out who you are and it wasn't really about the treasure, it was about the journey. And that's part of our mythological systems and the way that we tell stories. But why is the element of gold on our planet? So when you look at like most noble metals, and again, like I'm not a scientist, I'm sure somebody's going to say like, well, there's a billion caveats. And there are, but I'm trying to make this simple. Like most of those noble metals, like they're not very reactive um and that's because they come from the reactions inside of stars and they leave the star as gas because stars are just like these hydrogen processing like it's the most reaction chemical reactions that can ever take
一路上你发现了你是谁，这其实与宝藏无关，而是关于旅程。这是我们神话系统和我们讲故事方式的一部分。但为什么黄金这种元素会在我们的星球上？所以当你观察大多数贵金属时，同样，我不是科学家，我肯定有人会说，嗯，有十亿个注意事项。确实有，但我试图让它简单化。像大多数那些贵金属一样，它们化学性质不活泼，嗯，那是因为它们来自恒星内部的反应，它们作为气体离开恒星，因为恒星就像这些氢处理过程，就像是能在同一个地方发生的最剧烈的化学反应，
place in like one spot and so by the time something leaves it's pretty reacted with it's pretty inert and so you get these metals leaving as a gas and they go like out across the universe and so i mean because they're like in this gas across the universe there would have been some minuscule amounts of gold just like in the planet but you never would have been able to mine it or use it as a currency or um like have gold jewelry it would not have been common enough if it was not for the later period of our planet's history which is about 44 billion years ago and that's the heavy bombardment period and that's where these meteors from somewhere way outside of our solar system come into it
所以当东西离开时，它已经反应得很充分了，它相当惰性。所以你会得到这些作为气体离开的金属，它们会散布到整个宇宙。所以，我的意思是，因为它们像这样散布在宇宙中的气体里，地球上本来会有微量的黄金，但你永远无法开采它或将其用作货币，或者，嗯，像拥有金首饰，如果不是因为我们星球历史的后期，也就是大约44亿年前，那段重轰炸期，那才是这些来自太阳系外某个地方的陨石进入的时候，
and a ton of them hit the planet and they hit the planet and they go deep enough into the planet that they change its elemental formation and those meteors are carrying most of the gold that we use to do all the stuff we do with gold, including inform our understanding of how money and value work. And if they had missed, who knows what would happen, but because they hit, that is why we think of money the way that we do. So, you know, why is gold associated with money and currency at all? When you think about gold, yeah, you can use it for a billion things. You can hammer it into, you know, gold leaf and put it on the top of the Capitol building. You can coat, you know,
它们撞击地球，撞击得足够深，以至于改变了地球的元素构成，而那些陨石携带了我们用来做所有与黄金有关的事情的大部分黄金，包括形成我们对金钱和价值如何运作的理解。如果它们错过了，谁知道会发生什么，但因为它们撞击了，这就是为什么我们以这种方式思考金钱。所以，你知道，为什么黄金与金钱和货币联系在一起？当你想到黄金时，是的，你可以用它做十亿件事。你可以把它锤成，你知道，金箔，放在国会大厦的顶部。你可以涂层，你知道，
the lander craft in it to have a very light way when you're landing on the moon of reflecting electromagnetic radiation. Like you can do a zillion things with gold that are really useful. It's a very non-reactive, you know, conductor. But we, when we think of gold, we think of like money and coins and bars and gold finger and that kind of thing. Why? Um, well, gold is durable. It's divisible. Like you can usually get a coin and say, okay, I don't want to pay the whole coin. I want to pay half of it cut in half. It portable and that like it holds a lot of value in a very small package and so it's ideal um for like an exchange medium for a lot of reasons um but it also has just this intrinsic value into that it has a lot of luster like it's very pretty you can make it into jewelry because it reflects light well you know we like things like diamonds
着陆器，在月球着陆时用它来反射电磁辐射，这是一种非常轻便的方法。就像你可以用黄金做无数非常有用的事情。它是一种非常不活泼的，你知道，导体。但我们，当我们想到黄金时，我们想到的是钱、硬币、金条、金手指之类的东西。为什么？嗯，黄金是耐用的。它是可分割的。就像你通常可以拿一个硬币说，好吧，我不想付整个硬币。我想付一半，把它切成两半。它是便携的，因为它在很小的包装中容纳了很大的价值，所以它非常理想，嗯，作为一种交换媒介，有很多原因，但它也有一种内在价值，因为它有很高的光泽，它非常漂亮，你可以把它做成首饰，因为它能很好地反射光线。你知道，我们喜欢像钻石这样的东西，
and that reflect light you know historically um it's malleable in that you can bend it in a way you can't bend a diamond or a gemstone. It's ductile in that you can make it very small. It's not reactive, and it's not going to go away when you throw it in your treasure chest. So there's a lot of reasons that we use it as currency. So the use of metal coins started in 600 BC in ancient Lydia, which is now Turkey. And the coins were made from precious metals, usually gold, sometimes silver, and occasionally bronze for less valuable things. And the value was determined by weight and purity, and then the coins could be divided. And that's where the first coinage came from.
它们能反射光线。你知道，从历史上看，它是可延展的，你可以以一种无法弯曲钻石或宝石的方式弯曲它。它具有延展性，你可以把它做得非常小。它不活泼，当你把它扔进宝箱时，它不会消失。所以我们用它作为货币有很多原因。因此，金属硬币的使用始于公元前600年的古吕底亚，也就是现在的土耳其。硬币由贵金属制成，通常是黄金，有时是白银，偶尔是青铜，用于价值较低的东西。价值由重量和纯度决定，然后硬币可以被分割。这就是第一批铸币的来源。
And over time, gold became pretty widely accepted as the standard for money. And minting currency meant that you had control over what was going on in your empire and a little bit of propaganda or advertising because you put your god or your king's portrait on the money, which we still do. And, you know, so the scarcity of it and being afraid that what you were getting was not pure or it wasn't the right weight. You know, that's all stuff that just sort of became associated with money pretty early. Greeks, Romans, Egyptians, Persians. This isn't supposed to be a history lesson, but they all use metal coinage, and then that continues through the medieval and the modern period.
随着时间的推移，黄金被广泛接受为货币标准。铸造货币意味着你对帝国中发生的事情有控制权，还有一点宣传或广告的作用，因为你把你的神或国王的肖像印在钱上，我们现在仍然这样做。而且，你知道，它的稀缺性，以及担心你得到的东西不纯或重量不对。你知道，这些都是很早就与金钱联系在一起的事情。希腊人、罗马人、埃及人、波斯人。这不应该是一堂历史课，但他们都使用金属铸币，然后这种情况一直持续到中世纪和现代。
So in medieval Europe, the only people who knew how to test gold and do everything were goldsmiths, and so they were very trusted. And slowly, I think it happened at first during the Crusades with the Knights Templar, don't quote me on that, and the Hospitallers, where people started to issue paper money in the form of a receipt for gold. Because, you know, a treasure chest of gold, if you're going to drag that, you know, all the way from one country to the next country, you have to have a big wagon, you got to have a bunch of guards. Everybody knows that there's much gold in your thing because you are pulling it. And it's very heavy when you get a lot of gold. So even though gold's pretty portable in a huge volume, it becomes this liability because people see it and they kill you. You know, even if you have 20 guards and you have enough money to feed them and everything, then somebody just goes gets 40 because it's worth it to take all your gold.
所以，在中世纪的欧洲，唯一知道如何测试黄金并做所有事情的人是金匠，所以他们非常受信任。慢慢地，我想它最初发生在十字军东征期间，有圣殿骑士团，别引用我的话，还有医院骑士团，人们开始以黄金收据的形式发行纸币。因为，你知道，一箱金子，如果你要把它从一个国家拖到另一个国家，你必须有一辆大马车，你必须有一群守卫。每个人都知道你的东西里有很多金子，因为你在拉着它。当你有很多金子时，它非常重。所以即使黄金在巨大的体积下相当便携，它也变成了一种负担，因为人们看到了它就会杀了你。你知道，即使你有20个守卫，你有足够的钱养活他们和一切，然后有人就会去带40个人，因为拿走你所有的金子是值得的。
And if memory serves, the practice of issuing like a receipt for like debt money, paper money, started when people were trying to go to the Crusades because they didn't want to drag all this gold all the way, you know, through this bandit country of the desert. And on this journey, so the Knights Templar or the Hospitallers would have, you know, this big castle and you would go and you would dump your gold at the castle in France or England and then give you a receipt. And then when you got to Jerusalem or when you got to Malta or wherever you're going, then you go to another castle, you give them the receipt with the secret code or the wax seal. And then they say, okay, this is valid for the X amount of gold they give it to you. And so this idea that money existed at debt of gold started then
如果记忆没错的话，发行像债务货币、纸币这样的收据的做法，始于人们试图去参加十字军东征的时候，因为他们不想把所有这些金子一路拖过沙漠的强盗国家。在这段旅程中，圣殿骑士团或医院骑士团会拥有，你知道，这座大城堡，你会去那里，把你的金子倒在法国或英国的城堡里，然后他们给你一张收据。然后当你到达耶路撒冷或马耳他或任何你要去的地方时，你就去另一座城堡，给他们带有秘密代码或蜡封的收据。然后他们说，好吧，这对于X数量的黄金是有效的，他们把它给你。所以这种金钱作为黄金债务存在的想法就是从那时开始的，
and then became pretty common. And so most banking systems, if you ever look up Civil War money or, you know, they're gold certificates. They're not actually paper money. They wouldn't say that there. You can look at it and say this is valued at one troy ounce of blah, blah, blah. And those are like the old certificates with the gold leaf around them and everything. You still see them sometimes like on a movie or something. And that was because the paper was just the proxy. The gold was the thing. You're still using gold as money. You're
然后变得相当普遍。所以大多数银行系统，如果你查阅内战时期的货币，或者，你知道，它们是黄金凭证。它们实际上不是纸币。它们不会那样说。你可以看着它说，这价值一金衡盎司的某某某。那些就像带有金箔的旧凭证。你有时仍然能在电影里看到它们。那是因为纸只是代理。黄金才是本体。你仍然在使用黄金作为货币。你只是
just going and getting the money. You're keeping track of the gold that you own with paper because it's inconvenient to have gold in your pocket all the time. Same way that it's inconvenient to have cash in your pocket now. So what happened after World War I was that this idea of having, you know, a Fort Knox or a state treasury with a ton of gold in it that just sat there becomes, without going into a huge economics lesson. One, it's really expensive and it's very inconvenient. And then also you can't really change exchange rates and things as quickly. You can't print a whole bunch of Deutschmarks because your Deutschmarks are, you owe a whole lot of debt and reparations post-World War II.
去取钱。你用纸来追踪你拥有的黄金，因为一直把黄金放在口袋里很不方便。就像现在把现金放在口袋里很不方便一样。所以第一次世界大战后发生的事情是，这种拥有，你知道，诺克斯堡或国家金库，里面有大量黄金就放在那里，在不深入经济学课程的情况下，变得，第一，它非常昂贵，而且非常不方便。然后，你也不能很快地改变汇率之类的事情。你不能印一大堆德国马克，因为你的德国马克，你欠了大量的债务和赔款，在第二次世界大战后。
You can't do things like that. And so the ability to have a more flexible monetary policy meant that most people, in the U.S. it happened under Nixon. Nixon threw out the gold standard. It happened to most of Europe before the U.S. But money became fiat, which just meant it's what we are owed. The government is charging tax in that, and so you owe it back to the government as debt. But the short answer in all this is, or the short point is that
你不能做那样的事情。因此，拥有更灵活的货币政策的能力意味着大多数人，在美国是在尼克松时期发生的。尼克松抛弃了金本位制。这在大多数欧洲国家发生得比美国早。但货币变成了法定货币，这只是意味着它是我们被欠的东西。政府在其中征税，所以你作为债务欠政府。但所有这些的简短回答是，或者简短的观点是，
money at this point is backed by nothing. It is just paper. And the paper says that you have the full faith and credit of the US government instead of one ounce of Troy silver or gold or whatever, because what they're doing is saying, you know, this money is worth something because you are banking on the United States or the government of France or whatever still existing. And so even though we no longer have a gold standard, even though we no longer use money as gold, the idea of what money is comes from our relationship to this precious metal. And that we weren't using something else as money, like a social currency or a gift economy or an exchange economy or barter economy. I mean, that all came even though we don't have gold anymore. We still base money on this idea of gold.
此时的货币没有任何东西支持。它只是纸。纸上说你拥有美国政府的全部信用，而不是一盎司金衡白银或黄金或任何东西，因为他们所做的是说，你知道，这笔钱值钱是因为你押注美国或法国政府或任何政府仍然存在。所以即使我们不再有金本位制，即使我们不再使用黄金作为货币，金钱是什么的想法来自于我们与这种贵金属的关系。而且我们没有使用其他东西作为货币，比如社会货币或礼物经济或交换经济或易货经济。我的意思是，这一切都来了，即使我们不再有黄金。我们仍然基于这种黄金的想法来建立货币。
And even things like cryptocurrencies and NFTs that are supposed to blow up this whole idea of money, it's just this digital asset saying you have this digital token that says that you have a percentage of this digital other thing somewhere else. I mean, they're still based on that idea of scarcity in our relationship with gold. We got all of our ideas from that. And if those asteroids had not hit our planet in the late bombardment period, we would have a different idea of what money is like. So, you know, what does money without gold look like? You know, the island of Yap is one example. There's also, you know, a couple, you know, in isolated or pre-industrial societies where there wasn't gold, people had this understanding that resources were meant to be shared or distributed
甚至像加密货币和NFT这样本应引爆整个金钱概念的东西，也只是这种数字资产，说你拥有这个数字代币，说你拥有其他地方某处这个数字东西的百分比。我的意思是，它们仍然基于那种稀缺性的想法以及我们与黄金的关系。我们所有的想法都来自那里。如果那些小行星在晚期轰炸期没有撞击我们的星球，我们对金钱是什么会有不同的想法。所以，你知道，没有黄金的金钱是什么样子的？你知道，雅浦岛就是一个例子。还有，你知道，几个，你知道，在孤立或前工业化社会中，没有黄金的地方，人们有一种理解，即资源是为了被共享或分配的
evenly. They thought about it differently. You weren't trying to hoard things. You were trying to distribute them because if you're trying to distribute them, you have less of a target on your back and you're also seen as a more valuable member. So, um, you want to be exchanging things when you read like ancient Norse, um, you know, Beowulf and things like that. They, they have all these kennings that they use and they'll refer to Kings. A lot of times a kenning is where you talk about something, um, based on the, the sum of its parts. A description is what it is so like a foam crashing wave crusher
均匀地。他们以不同的方式思考它。你不是试图囤积东西。你试图分配它们，因为如果你试图分配它们，你背后的目标就更少，你也被视为更有价值的成员。所以，嗯，你想在阅读古诺斯语时交换东西，嗯，你知道，贝奥武夫之类的东西。他们，他们有所有这些他们使用的肯宁语（kennings），他们会提到国王。很多时候，肯宁语是你谈论某事，嗯，基于其部分的总和。描述它是什么，所以像泡沫破碎的波浪粉碎者
is a boat or the like sea faring like um sea beasts or something or whales and a lot of times they say that the glad-handed ring giver is a king because the kings were only kings in north society because they were proving that they could get a lot of stuff to give away. It was more of a gift economy than we have now, even though they did have gold. And so like in a lot of these cultures, the safety did not come from hoarding things or from scarcity. It came from generosity and compassion, not just hoarding material goods. And so other people took care of each other because they knew that when they needed help, others would take care of them. And that other people took care of each other because they knew that when they needed help, others would take care of them. And that was the social insurance and the social merit.
是船，或者像海上的，嗯，海兽或什么的，或者鲸鱼。很多时候他们说，乐于助人的戒指给予者是国王，因为国王在诺斯社会中之所以是国王，是因为他们证明了他们能得到很多东西来分发。这比我们现在拥有的更像是一种礼物经济，尽管他们确实有黄金。所以，在很多这些文化中，安全感不是来自囤积东西或稀缺性。它来自慷慨和同情，而不仅仅是囤积物质财富。所以其他人照顾彼此，因为他们知道当他们需要帮助时，其他人会照顾他们。而其他人照顾彼此，因为他们知道当他们需要帮助时，其他人会照顾他们。而那
It functioned the way insurance does now that, you know, everyone saw you feeding this hungry guy. So when you're hungry, maybe they'll feed you, you know, if your family is put in that situation. So in these barter and communal and gift economies, you know, power was not the most precious resource. Instead, reputation and social merit were the most precious resources. And because wealth and value can't be hoarded materially, you can't just put a whole bunch of social merit in a closet and then even though everyone hates you in a year, be like, hey, look, no, still go to the social merit. That's not how it works. You know, it didn't let people accrue value through scarcity. They had to be an active member of a system.
是社会保险和社会功绩。它的功能就像现在的保险一样，你知道，每个人都看到你在喂这个饥饿的人。所以当你饿的时候，也许他们会喂你，你知道，如果你的家庭陷入那种境地。所以，在这些易货、公共和礼物经济中，你知道，权力不是最宝贵的资源。相反，声誉和社会功绩是最宝贵的资源。而且因为财富和价值不能在物质上被囤积，你不能只是把一堆社会功绩放在壁橱里，然后即使一年后每个人都讨厌你，说，嘿，看，不，仍然去社会功绩。这不是它的运作方式。你知道，它没有让人们通过稀缺性来积累价值。他们必须是一个系统的积极成员。
They had to be accruing value by being useful and inventive and generous and civic, civically minded. So, you know, these systems rewarded people who innovated and who lived compassionately because societal regard becomes, when you don't have the ability to hoard wealth materially, societal regard becomes the most important resource, not electronic debt or precious metal. And so, you know, again, that's because things like food, clothing, tools, they all lose their value. You can't hoard those because the tools, all that stuff loses its value. And so people are incentivized to share and live communally in gift economies because clout and reputation become more valuable than any one good or resource or service. And so these systems are empowering because when need arises, society is naturally incentivized to meet those needs, not ignore them. And material wealth is always decreasing in value, so social wealth has more value.
他们必须通过有用、有创造力、慷慨和具有公民意识来积累价值。所以，你知道，这些系统奖励那些创新和富有同情心生活的人，因为社会尊重变得，当你没有能力在物质上囤积财富时，社会尊重成为最重要的资源，而不是电子债务或贵金属。所以，你知道，再次强调，这是因为像食物、衣服、工具这样的东西，它们都会失去价值。你不能囤积那些东西，因为工具，所有那些东西都会失去价值。所以人们被激励去分享和过公共生活，在礼物经济中，因为影响力（clout）和声誉变得比任何单一商品或资源或服务更有价值。所以这些系统是赋权的，因为当需求出现时，社会自然地被激励去满足这些需求，而不是忽视它们。物质财富的价值总是在下降，所以社会财富更有价值。
And value is stored in the social ledger of reputation, not in a material or electronic ledger of debt. And so in a debt and precious metals based system, value is disempowering because wealth tends to snowball. You know, the people who have more money in a system like ours, they have access to more power. And so they are likely to use that power to get more money and rinse and repeat. And the money tends to snowball in a couple of people. I don't know the statistic. Again, this isn't about economics or changing our current system. It's just about reflecting on the nature of ideas and our conceptions about them. But I think like, you know, something like five or two, two or 5% of the world owns like 89% of
价值存储在声誉的社会账本中，而不是债务的物质或电子账本中。所以在一个基于债务和贵金属的系统中，价值是削弱权力的，因为财富往往像滚雪球一样。你知道，在我们这样的系统中拥有更多钱的人，他们有权获得更多权力。所以他们很可能会利用这种权力获得更多的钱，然后循环往复。钱往往在几个人手中滚雪球。我不知道统计数据。再次强调，这不是关于经济学或改变我们当前的系统。这只是关于反思思想的本质以及我们对它们的构想。但我认为，你知道，像，你知道，世界上5%或2%，2%或5%的人拥有像89%的
the money and you get close to 9% of the money, this teeny tiny bit. Um, so it's this, our system does not function the way these other systems did. So, um, in, in, in a system like ours and a system, um, where you're able to hoard material wealth, other people's problems economically, they become a good thing for me because they mean that other people have less power and I'm in competition with those people. And so the more social problems that we don't fix, the more safe I am, or it feels that way. Society also is a little less stable in certain ways. And so why does this non-perishable nature of metals like gold lead to scarcity, competition, and inequality? Well, like the scarcity of
钱，而你接近9%的钱，这极小的一点。嗯，所以这是，我们的系统不像这些其他系统那样运作。所以，嗯，在，在，在一个像我们这样的系统中，在一个，嗯，你能够囤积物质财富的系统中，其他人在经济上的问题，它们对我来说变成了一件好事，因为它们意味着其他人拥有的权力更少，而我正在与那些人竞争。所以我们不解决的社会问题越多，我就越安全，或者感觉是这样。社会在某些方面也稍微不那么稳定。所以为什么像黄金这样的金属的不可腐烂性质会导致稀缺、竞争和不平等？嗯，像稀缺性
precious metals, they allowed individuals and institutions to accumulate and hoard wealth. And then that creates this disparity of resources. And the accumulation of precious metals becomes a means of showing someone's economic power and social status. And that concentration of wealth in the hands of very few people led to economic inequality with limited access to resources for the majority of the population. It also incentivizes things like imperial war and conflict because the point of society doesn't become fixing problems because in our system, problems are kind of a good thing. You don't really want to fix all of them. But what you are incentivized to do is hoard power by really have happened in the other systems. You know, they would have one need and then they would go invade land and then try and live there. You know, there were still wars in pre-industrial society, but usually it had the purpose of taking care of a group. It wasn't just to go get more stuff to keep. That's a modern idea. So, you know, long story short, when the purpose of society becomes hoarding power instead of building sustainable or equitable systems, people don't really take care of each other. So is there an alternative system?
贵金属，它们允许个人和机构积累和囤积财富。然后这创造了这种资源差异。贵金属的积累成为展示某人经济权力和社会地位的一种手段。财富集中在极少数人手中，导致了经济不平等，大多数人口获得资源的机会有限。它还激励了像帝国战争和冲突之类的事情，因为社会的目的不再是解决问题，因为在我们的系统中，问题算是一件好事。你并不真的想解决所有问题。但你被激励去做的是囤积权力，这在其他系统中并没有真正发生。你知道，他们会有一个需求，然后他们会去入侵土地，然后试图住在那里。你知道，前工业化社会中仍然有战争，但通常它的目的是照顾一个群体。它不仅仅是为了去获取更多的东西来保留。那是一个现代的想法。所以，你知道，长话短说，当社会的目的变成囤积权力而不是建立可持续或公平的系统时，人们并不会真正照顾彼此。那么有替代系统吗？
Well, non-industrial societies, before they were gold, they were barter and gift economies, and they operated on different principles than we have now, like we just went over. And so some examples of what those were like is like in a gift economy, goods and services are given without the expectation of an immediate return. And so they tend to promote social cohesion. They tend to reinforce communal bonds. And by focusing on reciprocity and sharing, gift economies prioritize the well-being of the community as a whole. And moreover, barter and gift economies, they can be more environmentally sustainable compared to hoarding precious metal or debt-based systems because they rely on utilizing resources within the community. So you're promoting local production, and that local production means that things are made here.
嗯，非工业化社会，在它们有黄金之前，它们是易货和礼物经济，它们按照与我们现在不同的原则运作，就像我们刚才讨论的那样。所以一些例子，它们是什么样的，就像在礼物经济中，商品和服务是在没有立即回报预期的情况下给予的。所以它们倾向于促进社会凝聚力。它们倾向于加强社区纽带。通过关注互惠和分享，礼物经济优先考虑整个社区的福祉。此外，易货和礼物经济，它们可以比囤积贵金属或基于债务的系统更具环境可持续性，因为它们依赖于利用社区内的资源。所以你在促进本地生产，而那种本地生产意味着东西是在这里制造的。
You're not going to where the workers have the least power because my point is to hoard things and I want to be able to pay the least. So I'm going to go to China or Mexico and build my factory there. You're incentivized to build things locally. So when you're manufacturing things on site, you don't have all of the carbon costs of long distance trade. You don't have things like a disposable supply chain and disposable infrastructure. That's another part of Before this starts to sound too much like a college, an econ class, just wrap up the difference in the way that societies without
你不会去工人权力最小的地方，因为我的目的是囤积东西，我想能够支付最少的钱。所以我去中国或墨西哥在那里建我的工厂。你被激励在本地制造东西。所以当你在现场制造东西时，你没有长途贸易的所有碳成本。你没有像一次性供应链和一次性基础设施这样的东西。那是另一部分。在这一切开始听起来太像大学，一堂经济课之前，总结一下社会在方式上的差异，没有
a precious metal system conceive of money versus the way that societies without a precious metal system conceive of money versus the way that we do. You know, social relationships and trust are a huge thing, whereas in our system, they're almost kind of a problem, you know, to being able to hoard money. Also, non-monetary transactions by passing money entirely by putting value directly in the thing. That's another characteristic of a gift economy. There's also this kind of abundance mindset. Like people are thinking about how much stuff they have and not scarcity. So they're reacting based on like,
贵金属系统构想金钱的方式与我们构想金钱的方式。你知道，社会关系和信任是一件大事，而在我们的系统中，它们几乎是一种问题，你知道，对于能够囤积金钱而言。此外，非货币交易通过直接将价值放入事物中来完全绕过金钱。那是礼物经济的另一个特征。还有这种丰裕心态。就像人们在思考他们有多少东西，而不是稀缺性。所以他们的反应是基于，嗯，
what do I want? I could go do this. I could do that. Not like, oh, I don't have that. I don't have a car. I don't have this kind of shoe. I don't have that brand, which is kind of the defining feature of a debt economy is scarcity. Whereas the other mindset is like abundance where you're just thinking about like, what need can I meet? And you're thinking about meeting other people's needs, not what you can do for yourself more, um, more often. And none of this is an absolute, of course. Um, so there's also a lot of like social obligation and prestige. You get cultures that are based more around doing big, you know, festivals, ceremonies, very social things. Because if you're keeping this ledger as reputation, you have to have everybody there. You have to have a
我想要什么？我可以去做这个。我可以做那个。而不是像，哦，我没有那个。我没有车。我没有这种鞋。我没有那个品牌，这算是债务经济的一个定义特征，即稀缺性。而另一种心态是丰裕，你只是在思考，嗯，我能满足什么需求？你在思考满足其他人的需求，而不是你能为自己做更多，嗯，更频繁。当然，这一切都不是绝对的。嗯，所以还有很多像社会义务和声望。你得到的文化更多是基于做大型，你知道，节日、仪式、非常社交的事情。因为如果你把这个账本作为声誉来保存，你必须让每个人都在那里。你必须有一个
lot of people together and you have to have a lot of social infrastructure and holidays and all these things so that you can keep track of, you know, who's doing what and everybody's role in the system, which overall is kind of a more psychologically healthy thing because we're not just kind of on TikTok yelling about different things, but we're, you know, engaging together. There's more reciprocity and sharing. And the big thing is that there's this notion of individuality, not the collective, of competition, of ego, the me, you know, and scarcity. And those things have, you know, maybe some benefits or they're needed in moderation. But when you're looking at these two systems, you know, one of them is less healthy. And again, like I'm not advocating that we go like barter beaver furs and burn our money.
很多人在一起，你必须有很多社会基础设施和假期以及所有这些事情，这样你才能追踪，你知道，谁在做什么以及每个人在系统中的角色，这总体上是一种心理上更健康的事情，因为我们不仅仅是在TikTok上对不同的事情大喊大叫，而是，你知道，在一起互动。有更多的互惠和分享。而最大的事情是，有一种个人主义的概念，而不是集体，竞争，自我，我，你知道，和稀缺性。而那些事情有，你知道，也许一些好处，或者它们在适度的情况下是需要的。但当你观察这两个系统时，你知道，其中一个不太健康。再次强调，我的意思是，我不是主张我们去，你知道，易货海狸皮并烧掉我们的钱。
That's not the point of this. It's just to think about something as subtle as money, what it is, you know, kind of affects our take on life. And there is a, a power and a psychology and a lot of things where we don't always think that there is psychology and things like economy. That's why we did the series on the psychology of architecture, on urban design of music. music, because I do think that these things are all part of mental health. And a lot of times when we talk about mental health, we just say like, okay, we'll eat 10 pieces of broccoli and drink water and think healthy thoughts. And I think that psychology is bigger than that and mental health is bigger than that. And being able to think about some of these things abstractly gives us some more clarity
那不是这个的目的。这只是去思考像金钱这样微妙的东西，它是什么，你知道，某种程度上影响了我们对生活的看法。而且有一种，一种权力和心理学以及很多事情，我们并不总是认为有心理学，在像经济这样的事情中。这就是为什么我们做了关于建筑心理学、城市设计、音乐的系列。音乐，因为我确实认为这些事情都是心理健康的一部分。很多时候当我们谈论心理健康时，我们只是说，好吧，吃10块西兰花，喝水，想健康的想法。而我认为心理学比那更大，心理健康比那更大。而能够抽象地思考其中一些事情给了我们更多的清晰度
on the way that we think. So, you know, in conclusion, what is the point? Why talk about cold and history for an hour? Well, I think that when we assume the ways that our culture works or our systems work are the only way that they can ever work, That's a huge hindrance to our intuition and our creativity, and it stifles our ability to imagine a better world, which is one of the points of me being a therapist, or a lot of people being a therapist, is that you want to find the world better, you know, when you die than you found it. You want to leave it better than you found it, which is why, you know, I see patients for eight hours a day.
关于我们思考的方式。所以，你知道，总之，重点是什么？为什么要谈论黄金和历史一个小时？嗯，我认为当我们假设我们的文化运作方式或我们的系统运作方式是它们唯一能运作的方式时，这对我们的直觉和创造力是一个巨大的阻碍，它扼杀了我们想象一个更美好世界的能力，这也是我作为治疗师，或者很多人作为治疗师的观点之一，就是你想要找到世界更好，你知道，当你死的时候，比你发现它的时候。你想要让它比你发现它的时候更好，这就是为什么，你知道，我每天看病人八个小时。
So, you know, just thinking about if those asteroids had missed our planet billions of years ago, they dumped the gold back into the black void of space and we never had enough of it to build a system like this. What would our culture or our monetary system look like? Would it look anything like this? And, you know, again, the point is not to say we should get rid of all the gold and build another system. It's to just kind of think about people say that this system is human nature or that this is just how it works. And I'm advocating for like, maybe it doesn't, you know, maybe some of these things are affected by material reality and we're just kind of water that is filling a vessel, but it's not our humanity that's doing this. It's a humanity maybe that is unchecked, but we can check it and we can think about these systems for a minute. Many people misquote the Bible that money is the root
所以，你知道，试想一下，如果那些小行星在几十亿年前错过了我们的星球，它们把黄金抛回了黑暗的太空虚空中，而我们从未拥有足够的黄金来建立这样一个体系。我们的文化或货币体系会是什么样子？它会像现在这样吗？而且，你知道，再次强调，重点并不是说我们应该抛弃所有的黄金去建立另一个体系。而是想让大家思考，人们常说这个体系是人性使然，或者这就是它的运作方式。而我主张的是，也许并非如此，你知道，也许其中一些事物受到物质现实的影响，我们就像是填充容器的水，但并不是我们的人性在做这件事。这可能是一种未受约束的人性，但我们可以约束它，我们可以花点时间思考这些体系。许多人误引了圣经中关于金钱是万恶之源的说法
of all evil. The Bible doesn't say that money is the root of all evil. It says that the love of money is the root of all evil. know we all interact with money daily but we rarely think about what it is and the way that we think about money and the way that thinking about money changes the role that it plays in our lives and how we behave and we often talk about values in this abstract way like you know a stand-up guy, or, you know, I want there to be president with character, or I want there to be somebody who fights for whatever, but those are abstractions of values. I mean, think about what value actually is. You're saying like, what is the, what is something that, what gives this thing worth? Is it because it's shiny and it has high luster and high
其实圣经并没有说金钱是万恶之源。它说的是对金钱的贪爱是万恶之源。我们每天都与金钱打交道，但我们很少思考它究竟是什么，以及我们看待金钱的方式，还有这种看待金钱的方式如何改变了它在我们生活中的角色，以及我们的行为方式。我们经常以这种抽象的方式谈论价值观，比如，你知道，一个正直的人，或者，你知道，我希望有一位有品格的总统，或者我希望有一个能为某种目标而奋斗的人，但这些都是价值观的抽象概念。我的意思是，想想价值究竟是什么。你是在说，什么东西赋予了这件东西价值？是因为它闪闪发光，具有高光泽度和高
malleability? Or is it because it fills needs in society and takes care of people and makes things better? You know, we want values to be this thing that is this easy thing to just kind of say and dismiss, but we don't really want to think about what we value as people. And the heart of this article is to make you think about what you value about yourself and what you value about the world and what we as a culture should value differently, or place value in different places. We don't always think about what value itself actually is. How do we decide what has worth and what doesn't? When these assumptions about what is valuable and good, and what the point of our society should be, it's often based on outdated and unhealthy assumptions that it should occur to us to reconsider. And so by moving away from a mindset that prioritizes individual accumulation, gift economies, encourage a sense of collective responsibility and interconnectedness, and I
延展性吗？还是因为它满足了社会需求，照顾了人们，让事情变得更好？你知道，我们希望价值观成为一种容易说出口且不假思索的东西，但我们并不真正想去思考作为人我们到底看重什么。这篇文章的核心是让你思考你对自己看重什么，对世界看重什么，以及我们作为一个文化群体应该在哪些方面有不同的价值观，或者将价值置于不同的地方。我们并不总是思考价值本身到底是什么。我们如何决定什么有价值，什么没有？当这些关于什么是宝贵的、什么是好的，以及我们社会的目标应该是什么的假设，往往基于过时且不健康的假设时，我们应该重新考虑。因此，通过摆脱优先考虑个人积累的心态，礼物经济鼓励一种集体责任感和相互联系感，而我
think a little bit of that post-COVID would be good. This shift in perspective can have positive effects on our mental health, and it can promote a sense of belonging and trust and reducing feelings of isolation, paranoia, competition. So go volunteer some time. You know, don't just say, well, I'm a good person because I gave some debt-based money to a charity. What are you really doing? What are you teaching your kids to value? Are you taking walks in the woods? Are you taking care of your health more than your career? You know, and we live in a world with a ton of limitations, so it's not like we can just
认为在后疫情时代，这一点会很有益处。这种视角的转变可以对我们的心理健康产生积极影响，它可以促进归属感和信任感，并减少孤独感、偏执和竞争感。所以去花点时间做志愿者吧。你知道，不要只是说，嗯，我是一个好人，因为我给慈善机构捐了一些基于债务的钱。你到底在做什么？你在教你的孩子看重什么？你会在树林里散步吗？你是否比关注职业生涯更关注自己的健康？你知道，我们生活在一个充满限制的世界里，所以我们不能就这样
all throw these away, but we should think about it. You know, most of the patients that I see suffer from profound sense of separation and disconnection in the middle of one of the most popular populated areas. They just feel totally alone. And, you know, our civilization would benefit from assuming the intrinsic value of all beings and the importance of meeting collective needs rather than amassing individual wealth. And not just in economics, but in our lives, like we should prioritize collaboration and generosity, and then we should move away from an emphasis on individuality, competition, ego, and scarcity. And we do that when we're afraid. And if we can work on being less afraid, I think that we're going to be able to collaborate and be more generous and
把这一切都抛弃，但我们应该思考一下。你知道，我见到的大多数病人都遭受着深刻的分离感和疏离感，尽管他们身处人口最稠密的地区之一。他们感到完全孤独。而且，你知道，如果我们的文明能够假设所有生命都具有内在价值，并重视满足集体需求而非积累个人财富，那将大有裨益。这不仅是在经济学上，在我们的生活中也一样，我们应该优先考虑合作和慷慨，我们应该远离对个人主义、竞争、自我和稀缺性的强调。当我们感到恐惧时，我们就会那样做。如果我们能努力减少恐惧，我想我们将能够合作并变得更加慷慨，并且
be more healthy. You know, what a person or society values is one of the best indicators of who they are, what it is. And so reflect on what you unconsciously place value in and what that says about who you are. We have a limited time on, and it's important to stay in touch with what we want the purpose of our life to be. So, in conclusion, where does your worth lie? What makes you valuable? We talk a lot about in therapy about, like, this doesn't make you lovable. You know, your weight or your bank account or whatever, that's not what makes you lovable. What do you think does make you lovable?
变得更健康。你知道，一个人或一个社会看重什么，是衡量他们是谁、是什么的最佳指标之一。所以，反思一下你潜意识里看重什么，以及这说明了你是怎样的人。我们在世上的时间有限，保持与我们想要的生活目标相联系是很重要的。所以，总结一下，你的价值在于哪里？是什么让你变得有价值？我们在治疗中经常谈论，比如，这并不能让你变得可爱。你知道，你的体重或你的银行账户什么的，那不是让你变得可爱的理由。你认为什么才是让你变得可爱的理由呢？
Who are you? That is the point of this thought experiment. And I'm going to end with a poem from Robert Frost called Nothing Gold Can Stay. Nature's first green is gold, her hardest hue to hold. Her early leaf's a flower, but only so an hour. Then leaf subsides to leaf, so Eden sank to grief. So dawn goes down to day, nothing gold can stay. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你是谁？这就是这个思想实验的重点。最后，我将以罗伯特·弗罗斯特的诗《金子总会褪色》（Nothing Gold Can Stay）作为结束。大自然最初的绿色是金色的，这是她最难保持的色调。她早期的叶子是一朵花，但只能维持一个小时。然后叶子退化为叶子，伊甸园就这样沉沦于悲伤。所以黎明走向白昼，金子总会褪色。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。